ladies and gentlemen I have a story for
you about
a young liberal leftist type social
media content creator being destroyed so
bad in debate he was at he admitted
himself to the emergency room and then
posted photos of him at the hospital
with an IV in
he claimed in a Twitter space hosted by
Nuance bro we've had on the show before
that 30 percent of the entire black
population are are unarmed and killed by
the police every year
yes he is this is from gain of fauci on
Twitter yes he is claiming that over 13
million unarmed black people are killed
yearly okay the first thing I want to
say is Nuance bro swears every other
word in this clip normally we try to be
family friendly with no swearing but
there's going to be a lot of swearing
for you now because I do think you need
to hear this
to this young man Jeremy who admitted
himself to the ER I will simply say I
hope you're doing better you need to
breathe breathe in the internet is not
that serious if people are are
criticizing you online because you were
wrong about something it's not the end
of the world you can always go play some
soccer and and read some fresh air and
maybe this job's not for you but I think
there is something profound in this
moment that is worth talking about so
I'm gonna play for you now this clip
from Nuance Pro on Twitter and then and
then show you the chain of events which
led to the leftist losing the debate so
bad he went to the ER all right we'll
play it tell me 13.2 million black
people are getting shot and killed
unarmed every year
there is contacts to that there's
definitely contacts to those numbers
dude you're crazy dude that's
like the Holocaust every black
person would be dead in like
three years like what are you talking
about that's crazy what are you saying
yeah we're still dying
yeah
Jeremy do you know what the actual
answer is because I actually have the
real numbers I like you've clearly never
done it this is I'm I'm mind
blown right now dude the real number
by Washington Post keep tracks of this
unarmed black people shot by police
men and women
usually like 10 people dude
it's like 10 maybe like 20 in a year
sometimes it's like eight you know
averages 10 or 13 million like 22 Maybe
like that's what it is
not million like I want to pause real
quick and point a few things this this
individual Jeremy is a content creator
for Gen Z for change which is a liberal
political action Social Media Group they
try to argue that gen Z is Progressive I
think this is a is a pro is propaganda I
think the goal of a group like gen Z for
change is to try and convince young
people that all the young people are
progressive and if you want to fit in
you have to be this way too
conservatives need to get on board with
this but let me let me play this for you
so you can hear after being told 13
million black people are not being
killed every year listen to how he
responds
uh I'm gonna have to do more research if
you send me the link you were claiming
like what was the number
Jonathan 30 13.
13.2 million you said 30 of the entire
black population that is crazy you're
wrong
if Harry and Chris were in here even
right he said I actually believe that
like 20 to 30 percent double down they
would be like dude what the we
gotta tell at least the fire this guy
this guy's nuts like he's out of
his mind he's smoking more crack
than uh Hunter Biden
that's why Chicago's worth of black
people yeah
they don't have enough bullets to
do that probably is 15 to 20
fair then
no that was it Lance wasn't as wrong as
that poor guy is like this guy
this guy compromise
like I can't believe have you never
talked to anybody like about this issue
15 to 20 is that more fair I only got to
say two things I don't wish any ill will
on on this guy Jeremy okay I don't he
seems like he's a good guy he's good
good but good intent to Pat the house
paid with good intentions I'll say the
two I'll say two things one if you
genuinely believe what you're saying you
should probably resign this not is not
the job for you following this this
young man admitted himself to the ER do
I have a here we go he says my heart is
racing this has not been a good night
going to the ER he then posted a picture
of himself getting an IV and then posted
a picture of himself in the emergency
room okay
if you have to go to the emergency room
because you were wrong about something
this is not the job for you and I
addressed this saying I made an arrogant
comment about the rate of unarmed black
men being shot by police in this country
I own that mistake and I'm sorry I was
wrong
he then goes on to mention uh Tim
mention he gets swatted so he must
understand this show some Grace please
is the point I made look this is not the
job for you if that resulted in you
going to the ER we've had this place
evacuated because of bomb threats we
were swatted 15 times plus several other
non-swotting incidents like bomb threats
other fake calls that resulted in forced
evacuation and dogs slipping through the
building I never had a panic attack I
never had a breakdown I never had to go
to the hospital because of it if that's
you man and I'm saying this with all due
respect not not derisively I'm saying I
don't think you should do this because
it gets worse than it is now was he
admitted for the same depression John
Federman had I don't know but the the
point is simply this
here's what I think happened
I think the reason he went to the ER I
think he probably his heart was about to
erupt from his chest I think this is
exactly what I've explained with the
social media crisis here's a young man
he's gen Z
he's probably what he's how old is he
he's probably 20 something years old so
he's eight or nine years old 2008 2009
perhaps
that was the time when the only things
you'd get on your social media feed was
police brutality videos
so these little kids sign up for
Facebook for the first time and it's
their first view of the whole world in a
single picture and they get nothing but
police brutality on Facebook companies
were making massive money off of this he
then grows up in an environment of
BuzzFeed my Covington post advice saying
the same thing over and over and over
again and he genuinely believes as he's
older there is a current Holocaust
against black people going on why don't
people care then he decides to debate it
and he tells people that he genuinely
believes he said that 20 to 30 percent
of black people are killed every year yo
I gotta be honest if that was the case I
would be out there with antifa and we
would be like it's time to put an end
I'd be in the Civil War we we would if
there was that kind of stuff going on
sounds like he's describing the Civil
War that's millions of people are dying
so but so what happens then if 20 years
of your life is proven wrong in an
instant and you are being ripped to
shreds mocked your entire life wrong
your entire body of work wrong you have
a mental breakdown you have a panic
attack you fall to your knees you can't
breathe what have I done with my life
what is your life you go to the hospital
I'm not surprised that happened to him
and I am not surprised that someone
whose life was just ripped from their
chest had to go to the emergency room
everything he thought was wrong
everything it doesn't help that people
like uh LeBron James say that black men
are being hunted in the street exactly
you know these young people genuinely
think there's like a holocaust or
something going on it's it's told that
they're they're told over and over and
over that they must be afraid of
the police they must be afraid of uh
basically just overall Society because
it's out to get you they are told that
they have to be afraid of climate crisis
we're there's no wonder that that
there's a mental health crisis with
young people today because they've got
this machine in their pocket that's just
dumping the most Doom and Gloom stories
you can possibly imagine all the time
yeah think about it like what's gonna
happen it can go one of two ways
um what do you think would happen to
like a die-hard atheist if the second
coming actually happens like their whole
world view flashing before their eyes or
for a Christian to see the inverse all
of their faith being ripped from them
not to assert either it's true or not
sure I'm saying to to dedicate your
whole life to a cause and then in an
instant it is ripped from your soul I
mean if you ever hear stories of people
talking about leaving Cults right if
you're raised in a cult that has a very
strong uh ideology and belief coming to
the other side can be really
traumatizing and shocking because
everything you've ever known is false I
mean the the thing that stands out to me
most about this is the double think
right it's uh he hears that the number
is basically 10 unarmed black people are
killed by police each year and he lowers
his stats by 50 so he goes from 1.3
million to like no it's 13 million 13
million to to he said he went from 30 to
20 to 30. yeah to 15. okay you said it's
10. so I'll say it's 6.5 million and
we'll call it a day like he does not
need stats or logic to back him up and
that's what I find concerning if if he
was taught by someone oh it's 30 million
black people and he knows the basic
population of black people in the world
or in in America he should be able to
figure out how much that is where did
this number come from you'd be able to
see that it's false you would you would
hear about it Non-Stop and when
confronted with the actual information
he's like well I'm not as I'm not
completely wrong I'm only partially
wrong it's 15 it's half of what I said
it was which is still wrong nothing that
would be wrong by millions Wrong by
millions the actual number he's still
going to stick with most of what he said
well just to point out his group was
also this gen Z for change I think they
were previously called tick tockers for
Biden no he described it as they the
media called them tick-tocks
and he got roasted for this because he
said we were called Tick Tock for Biden
but we are non-partisan just trying to
get young people blah blah this is what
the Democrats do better than
conservatives
conservatives are so are so stodgy and
uncool like look man I I was at the
skate park the other day and I'm
skateboarding and there's a bunch of
young people there wearing jeans baggy
T-shirts they got chain wallets I kid
you not I saw a couple kids wearing I
couldn't I was like it's 90s all over
again there's hope but this is where
young people are excited and and having
fun and looking up to people there's no
conservatives there the only politics
you'll probably hear in these places if
it does come up is going to be leftist
you get gen Z for change they go to
young people and say they show pictures
of young people you want to fit in you
got to believe these things
conservatives what do they do they show
up wearing suits to the school saying uh
I'm very cool with my suit kids don't
look up to that sorry dude like
this is what I see when I with all these
conservative you know action groups or
whatever they're all wearing suits and
it's just like this is not how regular
people act and young people aren't
looking up to you the same way if you're
going to young people wearing a suit the
only people that you're going to attract
is young people that would want to wear
a suit see I think there are young
people in the sphere that you're talking
about who are like not wearing suits
they're more you know they want to wear
flannels and do whatever you know they
look aesthetically hipster let's say uh
but they are afraid to call themselves
conservatives they they say oh well I'm
I'm uh you know traditional or I'm
libertarian but I lean more this way
they are afraid of being labeled with
the word conservative and so they avoid
it right it's the opposite of what
happens with being a you know a young
liberal you want to seem like the
coolest hippest most Progressive young
liberal and even if you look
aesthetically the same you're standing
out with your politics I think you have
conservatives who would fit that
aesthetic mold they are just afraid to
reveal themselves so what we have now is
Vivek ramaswamy saying if you want if
you're between the ages of 18 25 you've
got to pass a Civics test to vote after
that you can vote I don't think that
solves the problem I don't think age
determines I think there's a correlation
between age knowledge and wisdom but
it's not absolute there's a lot of
really young people who are very smart
and have worked really hard they
shouldn't be excluded from voting or
forced to take a test at the same time
if there's going to be a requirement it
should be for everyone no matter what
you know I don't care but where we're at
now is the right tends to be like look
man these young people you need to prove
you know what you're talking about and
the left is like 16 year olds should
vote because the Democrats Thrive off of
ignorant voters who don't know they're
being lied to yep
um I tend to
agree that there should be a test a
Civics test
um I don't think that there should be an
age limit or anything like that
um I don't even know about a Civics test
I feel like without a test the reason
the reason the reason that I think they
should trust the people giving the test
about this before one of the things we
that he brought up was maybe when you
sign up for the Selective Service you
get a voter card and male and female you
both have to do it but you don't have to
do it if you choose not to sign up for
the for the Selective Service no voter
card you do sign up you get a voter card
plain and simple the reason that's a
good idea I think it's important for
people to know the way really understand
the way that our system works and the
reason is because right now we got
people that get so upset because someone
gets elected and they don't get the
results that they were hoping for and
then someone else gets elected and they
don't get the results they were hoping
for and the reason is because they're
hoping for things that they're the per
the politician they're voting for does
not have the power to do the politicians
constantly make promises about things
that they don't have any authority to do
and then they go ahead and
and get voted on that pretext if people
if more people that voted understood
what a politician does and does not
actually have the capability to do they
would at least have some kind of
reasonable expectations as opposed to we
can just elect this guy and then he'll
go ahead and fix the climate or make the
Sun come down you know like something
really stupid I think this is where a
lot of high schools have a Civics
requirement right like for most high
schools you have to pass a Civics course
to graduate this was true in you know
the state I grew up in I think it's true
in Massachusetts most of high school
curriculums you have to specifically
pass a Civics maybe it's not true
everywhere but I don't think they're
teaching this Civics are you teaching it
effectively right I mean what do you
actually need to know to Be an Effective
voter I do think that we should if we're
going to have a government our
government should be uh encouraging
people to pursue our values and one of
your values should be engagement in your
community so I don't think some kind of
Civic component to voting whether it's
just literally being aware of what the
rules are or you know Selective Service
being in the military I know Vivek has
First Responders I don't think that's
unreasonable I think we have just we're
fighting a culture of uh apathy people
feel like they should have the right to
vote even if they don't really ever
check the polls or see what's going on
in their local community I like the idea
we talked about this last week you have
to be a net taxpayer to vote
so think about how that would work if
the left might be like oh that's not
fair you know then the poor people will
get screwed over no they won't if the
people who are net taxpayers say we're
not going to allocate any tax funds to
poor people no social programs no
welfare all of a sudden it becomes very
very easy to become a net taxpayer if
you're not receiving any benefits from
the government that puts you at zero if
you then make ten thousand a year you
become a net taxpayer and you vote
if everyone then votes to allocate more
funding to people who are impoverished
poor people become not net taxpayers
they become tax liabilities or burdens
I'm not trying to be mean when I say
that but they're now taking more in
taxes than they're giving now they don't
vote because they're recipients of the
system
so it creates a kind of balance in and
of itself I'm not saying it's a perfect
idea it was an interesting idea but I
think it it could potentially work and
then the only people who are voting are
those who are actually paying into the
system for which other people get to
live off of a lot of the problems that
we're seeing or a lot of the problems
you see with voting are not you know
it's not new these ideas were
all things that uh the founders had
thought about you know talking about a
well-informed electorate and stuff like
that these are all the problems that
look in talking about things like when
when the electorate realizes they can
vote themselves uh you know benefits
from the government and stuff like that
that they're of course going to do that
all these things that have have
been predicted or or tried to be
prepared for in in our our Constitution
and the government has
continuously voted to give people some
kind of benefit or some kind of you know
some kind of something out of the out of
the government coffers and it's not just
you know welfare for poor people or
whatever this is talk I'm talking about
uh benefits for a company for entire
Industries to try and get them to you
know have a a spur on certain uh you
know Industries and stuff so the idea
that the the government or that the
population voting is going to fix the
problem I'm not sure because they they
vote for you know vote for the things
that get them the benefits and that's
part of what our government has become
you know so you take that away thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored third members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time